in today's morning rounds concerns over
using social media as a source for
medical advertising pharmaceutical
companies health care providers and
advocacy groups are turning to
celebrities and influencers to get their
messages out on social media regulators
are keeping a close eye though we spoke
to one influencer who usually posts
about fashion and travel and now she's
moving into personal health and she's
not alone I won't do anything that goes
against my my morals and my values
Ashley hey be southern suds and simple
living Instagram feed is filled with
paid lifestyle posts featuring food and
fashion but when Walgreens went looking
for an influencer to promote its flu
shot services they chose this mother of
four and her more than 17,000 followers
I've actually always utilized the
pediatrician for flu shots and last year
alone I think we waited like 2 or 3
hours and so I think I was just trying
to let my audience which is mostly moms
know that there are more convenient
options available a self-described
holistic mom hey B says her post was not
intended to advocate for or against flu
shots but she still got backlash from
vaccination opponents I don't usually
have something that is controversial and
obviously whether to vaccinate or not
vaccinate is a hot topic babies post
makes clear that Walgreens paid her but
regulators have cited other influencers
for not including the required
disclosures I'm Julianne Hough and I
have endometriosis actress Julianne
Hough was publicly criticized for her
Instagram posts raising awareness of
endometriosis which were actually
sponsored by the maker of a drug that
treats the disease her representative
told us she's no longer involved with
the pharmaceutical company and a Kim
kardashian-west post about a drug for
morning sickness prompted a 2015 warning
letter from the FDA which said it did
not include enough safety information
our dr. David agus has been looking at
the growing number of health-related
influencer post doctor David good
morning so we should mention at the top
ashley was talking about vaccines
vaccines are good they're important my
kids get them your kids should get them
but what are your bigger issues with non
doctors wading in on social media on
really
issues agree with you on vaccines thank
you for that the you know I think she
said it best when she said I follow my
morals and values and the problem is
health is you also have to follow the
data and so health is difficult it's
complex you know when you say a disease
there are dozens of subtypes to it so a
recommendation has context and when a
social-media influencer goes out there
and they have crazy power power for good
but also that power can cause problems
when they say things that don't make
sense you're talking about people with
no medical training here basically yeah
we're talking about people with medical
training that just doesn't exist right
yet they put out a statement hey I tried
this drug for arthritis and I feel
better yeah well what kind of nephritis
was it and you know somebody else
follows on that it could be real
problems other ways that social media
can be used for good in the medical
realm that's a great leading question
and the answer is yes it can be is
certainly Andy Grove went on the cover
of Fortune magazine in the 90s and
nobody who remembers that now but there
was the first and he said I have
prostate cancer and they really become
beacons of hope for people Lance
Armstrong when he had testicular cancer
was a beacon of hope for a cure and over
and over again we see people doing this
selma Blair did for multiple sclerosis
getting up there and demystifying a
disease and becoming a role model
awareness not advice it sounds like you
no question about that's a great
distinction and you're right but that
line gets blurry to get normative
behavior changed you need leadership and
leadership nowadays is followed by
social media influencers and that's a
lot of responsibility how hard wallis
and 30 what should we be asking when we
see influencers making these posts well
the first is is are they sponsored by
somebody the second is when they're
recommending a product you really have
to take a step back you know talking
about a disease providing information I
love but recommending products in health
just shouldn't be done in today's world
I'm gonna look for you on social media
Thanks they're sponsored they should say
it but they don't always that's a key
thing all right dr. David agus thanks